it's
God it's
God hello yeah how how you guys doing
man um so the reason why I'm not a
Muslim I'm a Christian by the way the
reason why I'm not a Muslim is because
uh the qu makes a lot of claims about
you know the Bible about what Jesus said
um it said that Jesus mentioned a man
named Offman to come after him and never
did we ever see Jesus ever mentioning
this so that's why I'm like okay so the
Quran makes false claims so I can't be a
Muslim if it's making false claims like
that okay do you have do you do you have
access to what God is referring to in in
that or you just you're just assuming
that oh he says that Jesus said all the
scriptures for you to make that exactly
well yeah yeah yeah well he said that
Jesus said this um we don't there's no
evidence that Jesus ever said this so
you know we got the evidence of the
contrary you're see you're not
understanding what God Said is the
evidence exactly you're you have you you
you don't have any evidence we got what
people saying he said
yes fellas this is yeah I hear what
you're saying because you're you're
assuming that the Quran is the word of
God right and so I know I know the angle
you guys are coming from I'm coming from
some qu claims that itself right I know
I I I get what you're saying I'm coming
from the outside looking in right I'm
not coming in with the assumption that
it's the word of God I'm critically
thinking about it so I can't just take
the claim tell you just haven't found
that information yet well no no it
doesn't exist it doesn't exist no
doesn't exist yeah I can it doesn't
exist you have anything that Jesus said
that was like written down every single
word word for word yeah we we have what
Jesus wrote down and nowhere do we see
him mentioning off meant to come after
him
Jesus wrote down I'm sorry that that
Jesus preached his disciples wrote it
down oh his disciples wrote it he wrote
it they wrote down every single thing
every single thing he preach yeah they
wrote everything that pertaining to
Revelation they wrote it down you know
very much so so if since Jesus didn't
say anything about Muhammad coming after
him and the Quran says he did then I
have to judge that the quran's false no
that's very much okay so so okay so you
take the other what the other thousand
statements in the Quran and you choose
to ignore those statements you choose to
follow this to to pick this statement
specifically that you wouldn't even be
able to prove whether you tried to or
not because it could not it could not
you don't have access to that type of
information to even find well so I'm
coming at like this brother
it's well no it's not no so this is what
I'm doing so I'm not just making a claim
right I'm studying what the Quran made
made a claim about I'm saying that the
Quran says something and I'm like okay
if it's the word of God then this would
be true if I check it and it's not true
then I have to judge that this is not
the word of God the Quran could get
everything else right right let's let's
say it got everything right if it got
one thing wrong is it the word of God
absolutely not no exactly so so I'm
saying if it this this one thing it gets
wrong uh you know along with others but
I'm saying this is one of the
examples because it's not it's not in
one of his 88 Bibles I'm saying that's
what you're not understanding that that
this information that you're talking
about that you're trying to compare the
Quran to is information that has not
been
information that has not been um um
safeguarded well well that's not true
the Quran says it was safeguarded no he
did not where where where you okay yeah
yeah for so so for example guys the
Quran says in chapter 2 verse 41 that it
came confirming what is with the Jews
and the Christians so it says that the
that they have the Torah and the gospel
they have it in Muhammad's time so it is
safeguarded right and so we have what
even existed prior to that so if I'm
looking in what we have what the Quran
says I have and I see that oh Jesus
never said anything like this then I
have to judge that the quran's
false absolutely not what you just said
is complete ignorance bro how how is it
ignorance you got to tell me how brother
statement that you just said saying that
the Quran says that everything that um
is proven everything that came in um
from the Jews from the Jews in so you're
trying to say that the Quran says
basically since it's proving that you're
trying to say that in this context the
Quran is also proving that Jesus is God
which would be a total contradiction
well well yeah that's that's the this is
what is called the Islamic dilemma the
Quran affirms the Bible and everything
in it however you you have clear places
where the Quran hold let me let me just
land this guys let me just land this no
no no no no no no not the Bible that you
guys
have yeah see see see I know what you
guys are saying right you guys are
saying that I don't have what the Quran
is confirming what the Quran is talking
about you're saying I don't have it and
I I get your
point Jesus himself I got it wasn't
preserved but okay so then what is it
that was with the Christians that the
Quran says they had what did they have
in Muhammad's time what do you mean it's
so m in the Quran it says that the
Christians have the inel they have the
gospel they have to judge by it the
Quran confirms it right they have to
follow it what is that that they have if
if if it's it says they have the gospel
message it would be the same original
message Jesus came
with so very good so then that means in
M I got you brother so in Muhammad's
time it means that in the seventh
century the gospel was still preserved
at least in Muhammad's time I have the
manuscripts that exist before that no
that's not what that would mean yes it
does no it doesn't okay so what expain
how that's what that that would mean
okay look brother so so the Quran says
that the Quran came right as a
revelation confirming what the
scriptures the Torah and the gospel with
the Jews and Christians it literally
says this it literally says confirming
the Torah and the and the gospel with
them so in Muhammad's time they have the
Torah they have the gospel the prophet
time as well they had in their books um
um uh descriptions of him right
Prophecies of the that's that's the
that's the claim the Quran makes and
that's why I'm testing it no
this actually happened this actually
happened what evidence okay
where in the when the prophet when um no
no no I know what you're talking about
look there there's claims that that the
previous scriptures have Muhammad's
mentioning in them my only thing is look
I'm testing that I'm saying okay where
is that show me that's what I'm
saying I don't I don't I don't
understand look look brother brother
it's it's like this it's it's like this
okay SC that was revealed to Jesus
well well it's it's like this right I'm
a Christian right so I I believe Jesus
is the Messiah most Jews don't right now
for me to prove to them that he's the
Messiah I have to say oh well the Old
Testament predicted his coming the Jews
would ask me where and so I would show
them from the Old Testament from the
Torah where it talks about the coming
Messiah okay so similar the Jews were
not in doubt about matter of fact let me
ask you this question the Jews were
never in doubt about Jesus they were
never in doubt they were what are you
talking about even the Quran talks about
how how they denied him they were never
in doubt about him being a prophet
because they knew yes they were they
accused him of sorcery and called him a
magician give me a second give me a
second all right
um why wasn't Mary right why wasn't Mary
killed for having Jesus even though
there was no there was no man because
you know according to the law every
single woman who who fornicates is is to
be killed right yeah so she actually her
pregnancy wasn't
public but she came with a baby yeah in
her
marriage huh no no no no no yeah
according to the story of Mary of Mary
she her pregnancy was not was not public
bro look look the Bible even says this
the Bible says that Joseph um you know
didn't want to out her publicly so he
decided to put to cancel their marriage
in secret but an angel came to him and
said hey she's actually pregnant uh you
know uh it's a miraculous birth from God
so don't worry about it so he kept his
engagement okay so let's not get away
from the subject though the subject is
that we're talking about is that what
was with the Jews and the Christians the
Quran says is good is true and is
authoritative and it me and it mentions
Muhammad ver is right here he said 21
verse 41 I said chapter 2 verse 41 I
said chapter 2 verse 41
guys is remember my is upon you PR your
Covenant and I
no guys guys that's the wrong verse
chapter 2 verse
41 yes that's see we don't we don't we
don't read one verse and then try to
take it out of context I'm reading the
verse before okay my
[Music]
bad alone standing All of Me Alone
believe in my Revelations which confirm
your scriptures do not be the first to
deny them or um trade them and be
mindful of me do not Mi truth or false
hide truth and hide the truth knowingly
establish prayer pay arms tax and bow
down with those who bow down now number
one the Jews the Jews themselves right
the
Jews they had the scriptures they
changed it with their own hand so they
know what the truth is okay so they know
where the the Christians the Christians
that's that's a whole another story was
answer the Jews
Allah literally says what what he's
talking about in the past the Covenant
no no read again well well you got to
read it out loud for the a we didn't get
to hear what you read so go ahead and
read it out loud
please starting from from if you got the
Quran with you you can read stting
chapter 2 verse 40 the verse before it y
context Allah says oh children of Israel
remember my favors upon you fulfill your
Covenant and I will fulfill mine and
stand in awe of me alone believe in my
Revelations this is the verse you're
talking about believe in my Revelations
which confirm your scriptures do not be
the first to deny them or trade them for
a fleet and gain and be mindful of me do
not mix the truth falsehood or hide the
truth knowingly establish prayer pay
arms tax and bow down with those who bow
down do you righteousness and fail to
practice it yourselves although you read
the scripture do you not understand so
you see notice how it said although you
read the scripture that means that they
have the scripture to read right and
verse 41 says verse 41 in your
translation it actually missed the key
point that I'm bringing up the word in
the Arabic
is let me
listen yeah can you guys hear
meab transl well well yeah scoffing
doesn't help guys like you you got to
hear the argument so look the verse says
that to believe in my revelation
right um which is confirming that which
is with you the word is which is with
you in the Arabic right so the Quran
says that their scriptures are there
with them yes okay good I said that okay
good so in Muhammad's time the
scriptures were there intact with them
and the Quran confirms it no way you
think you think that's what that that's
that's exactly what it said told you
Allah said oh children of Israel uhhuh
he's speaking to the children of Israel
yeah in what time he didn't he didn't
say oh Muhammad speak to Muhammad that
time no I know no no brother look what
are you saying there okay so for example
in verse let me read it again so you can
understand the context oh children of
remember my favors upon you fulfill your
Covenant and I will fulfill mine and
stay in awe of me alone doesn't change
who he's talking to believe in my
Revelations which confirm your script
do not be the first to deny them when
Allah says believe in my rations he's
speaking Quan confirm your know I'm
aware do not be the first to deny them
or trade them for a fleet and gain and
be mindful of me
okay to okay so yeah so let's let's
let's break it down so Allah is using
Muhammad to speak to the children of
Israel
correct okay yes okay boom so when he
says when Muhammad is saying right Allah
he's he's reciting the Quran to the
children of Israel and tells them
believe in my this is quoting Allah
believe in my
Revelation the Revelation that he's
telling them to believe in is the Quran
right my Revelations uhuh okay so he's
telling the children of Israel believe
in my Revelation the Quran which is
confirming that which is already with
you
so it's in the time that the Quran
came that Muhammad in the Quran is
telling the Jews to believe in the Quran
that confirms what they have already so
really they don't have an excuse to
disbelieve the Quran because the Quran
is in line with what they already have
yes yes they don't have an excuse to
disbelief okay all right so so good
we're on the same we're on the same page
so now look fellas so with this being
said this means that the scriptures that
they have with them during the time that
the Quran is being revealed is still
true and is still authoritative at least
for
them not not 100% not 100 it's 100% it's
not
partially they it literally says in the
Quran they Chang the word they knowingly
Chang this this verse right here proves
that Allah is telling them to follow the
Revelation that came well no no so look
their books and it was very very very
few who actually believed in the
authentic the authentic um scripture at
that time now now but here's the message
of the Quran in full okay CU I hear what
you're saying you're you're partially
right the Quran is telling them every
group the Jews the Christians and the
Muslims they have to believe in all of
Allah's Revelation they can't pick and
choose they have to believe in all the
books that's even part of your articles
of Faith right you got to believe in all
the books so denying no I'm I'm not
saying you're denying I'm just you know
just bringing it into perspective okay
so with that being said it's telling the
Jews and the Christians the people of
the book to follow to not just not
follow but believe in the Quran that's
also being revealed that that confirms
their scriptures so now they have a last
Revelation they have to affirm okay they
not just the Torah not just the inil not
just the Psalms but also the Quran now
okay yes so with this being said what
they have is true it's in line with the
Quran the quran's in line with what they
have and so therefore they should
believe in all the books including the
last the last Revelation this a but they
can also just like say yeah I believe in
the Quran but I'm gonna follow my B that
was revealed to me well they're supposed
to right so so yes they have to believe
in the Quran once the Quran was revealed
it was the governing legislation of no
sir no go to go go to chapter trust me
go to go to chapter five whenever
whenever a messenger comes right let me
give you a prime example uh John the
Baptist yeah was he preaching before
Jesus came you you tell me was preaching
the Torah when Jesus came then he
started preaching what Jesus was
preaching as well where I don't I don't
I'm not sure if the Quran says that but
I huh I said I'm not sure if the Quran
says that but I'll I'll I'll take your
word for for now Quan say this is from
the Prophet this is not from the Quran
this iset himself I got it I got you
okay so look if you go to if you go when
a new when a new message is being
revealed Who The Messengers
Moses David Solomon or Jesus you have to
you have to stop whatever that was
before and you have to follow the
messenger that's not
true I hear I hear what you're saying
let me show you that that's not true
okay let me tell you something let me
tell you something let me tell you
something this is why the Jews have
issues because they they believe in God
and they believe in Moses but they
didn't follow Jesus and Jesus was a
messenger sent to them from God I'm
saying I hear you so so look this is why
I'm going to say that that you're Raw on
the fact that they have to follow other
they have to stop following the law that
they previously had okay go to chapter
5: 43 for example
serida chapter 5:
43 okay what's that what did it say it's
gonna it's going to say that uh uh you
know that that some Jews were trying to
come to Muhammad for for judgment for a
decision and it says why do they come to
you for judgment when they have the
Torah in which Allah's judgments are in
but even still
Rebel right so they're supposed to be
using their Torah as their law yes yes
even in the time of the
Quran no me let me see the verse go to
it 543 bro what's the verse it's chapter
5 verse 43 543
boom said but why do they come to you
for judgment when they already have the
Tor um containing Allah judgment then
they turn away after all they are not
true believers exactly what what are you
saying so I'm saying I'm saying that
even though Muhammad is there with the
Quran the Jews are still supposed to
follow their Torah as their law they're
not no they decided to to not follow the
prophet Sall alall so the prophet Sall
alhi wasallam when he came to Medina he
told them y'all govern with your own
laws he told the whoever the the other
tribes they govern with their own laws
too so he was the leader of Med he gave
everybody their own Beast to to rule
their by their own way all right so so
answer be this for me brother why then
if that's the case if if the Quran is
the governing of is the governing law
now why does Allah say why do they come
to you Muhammad for judgment when they
have the Torah in which Allah's
judgments are in why does he point them
back to the Torah there two thing that I
I just repeated like four times bro I
just told you that the Jews they had the
book but they changed it knowingly with
their own hand right so they know what
they're doing is wrong so why is he
telling them to go back to a book that's
correct and changed they know what
they're doing is wrong they know right
from wrong they know what's actually in
the book and what they changed and what
they didn't I hear what you're saying
look listen I hear what you're saying
you're saying that that the Quran says
that God is telling them to go back to
what was originally revealed that they
know is true not what they changed with
their own hand no but it doesn't say
that though it says why do look look
look this is what the verse says my
brother
lookit look look it's a good one it's a
good day the Quran
says brother it says a whole lot of
people who are keep who keep just
staying away no no I'm I'm i' brother
I've been consistent on the same point
this entire time I've been the only
guest that's been consistent I haven't
jump yeah you the best out of
them I appreciate that so so look Bro
Look I hear what you're saying but there
what you're saying adds more of a
problem okay and here's why because I
don't want you to think that I don't
understand what you're saying you're
saying that the Quran says that they've
changed and distorted their books so
there's good parts in it there's bad
Parts in it the quran's telling them to
go to the good parts one the Quran never
says that go to the original one not the
good part the original one well it
doesn't say that it says that they have
the Torah bro it says they have it when
Allah refers to his scriptures obviously
when Allah talks about the
T guys I can't hear both of you guys at
the same time the one that was changed
that has nothing to do with him he not
claiming that okay cool so he's talking
about the Tor that's unchanged right yes
okay so that means that the Jews had the
unchanged Torah in Muhammad's
time oh my boom boom I just they're
changing it with their own head no it's
you just said ahh you just said it's
unchanged when he says they have the
Torah in which Allah's judgments are in
that's the unchanged Torah CH in it and
what is not changed in it that's the
point they know no bro see see now y'all
y'all are saying two different things
the other brother says that when it's
saying this it's talking about the
unchanged Torah you're saying well when
it's talking about the Torah it's
talking about the Torah that's corrupt
I'm telling you is the same thing they
change with their own hand but they know
what is true and what is false what they
change but hold on own the who change it
so then why look why in the world would
all no can I read for you the T so you
can understand I already know
the can I read for you the explanation
of what that verse means so that you
don't so that so that you or us don't
come up with any with any explanation
from ourselves so that you don't think
we you know what I like I like that what
who's the best tough who gives the best
tough Seer Muhammad or the other
Scholars Whoa
man come from the prophet okay so so who
who better explain stuff Muhammad or I
cir where do you think EV where do you
think EV gets his translations his own
stuff his own stuff
yes okay so okay I'm asking again who's
the better guys who's the better
explainer of the Quran is it Muhammad or
speak we speaking about our religion
don't try to don't try to don't try to
like brother I'm a shake man I'm a
shake all right you got the
FL where do you think gets from you
think he gets it from himself yes that's
absolutely false absolutely okay you can
say that that's fine SCH ever I
understand that I understand that all
I'm
asking I got you brother look all I'm
asking is who is a better uh explainer
of the Quran is it Muhammad or is it I
the best explainer of the Quran is theet
all right cool all right so let's go
straight let's go straight to Muhammad
where do you think isting I think I
think I think because because iir comes
way after Muhammad he is in he has a lot
he's getting he's getting a lot of stuff
from IA his
teacher something yo you talking you
talking about stuff that you don't have
knowledge of how do you know I don't
have knowledge of it tell me tell me
what knowledge you have because I'm
trying I'm trying to break it down for
you brother so look if we're going to
say that Muhammad is the best explainer
let's just go straight to how he
explained the verse so let's go to the
Hadith that's theith is where gets
information are you a fool okay so let's
okay if you're saying that let's go
straight to the no no no it's cool I
like his energy it's cool it's cool I
don't have to go straight to the came
with the with theth and he
no he doesn't not all the time let's go
straight to what Muhammad
said you think
just and of the Quran to prove verses no
no not all the time A lot of times it's
just them explaining things and they're
commentary and their interpretations of
stuff
bro anytime that says commentary that's
his his commentary that's literally what
a top is the what that's literally what
a top is what are you talking about top
means explanation exactly yes yes the
explanation they give commentary
explaining the
Quran there's commentary we don't we
don't consider that part of
theith that
part boom boom boom let's give let's
give him an example let's give him an
example right here
I that he thinks he understands let's
give him an example right I want to read
the Hadith of the verse you guys think I
don't understand let me read what
Muhammad
said all right let's let's hear what you
got to say when're not oh look if you
you guys got your phone right can you go
to go to sun.com go to uh
or or you just look up uh Sunan Abu da
4449 second give me a second 4449
okay 4449 you see how I got these on on
memory I told you I'm like that man I
think you got I'm like
that I'm like
that 4449
four boom
right okay this is I think this
talking give me a second this is okay
this is this is right here okay this
okay go
ahe yeah it's
Hassan 4449 go ahead yeah yeah the great
it's great Hassan go
ahead we listening bro oh oh sorry guys
I thought y'all was reading my
bad abely we need to see what you
talking about oh is it in front of you
guys all right I got to pull it up
myself I thought you guys hold on my bad
you got it on the notes no I don't have
it no no look okay it talk it talks
about I can paraphrase it it talks about
okay okay okay I'll pull it up I'll pull
it up I'll pull it up all right all
right haby
crazy I thought that was a term of
endearment huh I thought that was a term
of
endearment what I what I got why I gotta
be Muslim to use that I'm a
shake no no no no fellas I like that
energy he's he's cool man he's cool I'm
not a brother that's you got know saying
you got that's my brother right
here all right all right all right so
let me
um okay
saying I hear that they they can they
can spam it all they want it's great
Hassan it's Hass okay listen to what he
got to
say all right um all right I'm almost
there 444 4
five and if they want sah they can go to
4447 and sah anyway but anyway so 4449
all right here it is a group of
Jews a group of Jews came and invited
the messenger of Allah to KU so he
visited them in their school they said
uh Abul casim one of our men has
committed fornication with a woman so
pronounced judgment upon them they
placed a cushion for the messenger of
Allah who sat on it and said bring the
Torah it was then brought so the Torah
is there and there and he brought it
right they brought it he then withdrew
the cushion from beneath him and placed
the Torah on it saying I believe in you
and in him who revealed
you right he then said bring me one
who's learned among you then a young man
was brought the transmitter then
mentioned the rest of the tradition of
stoning similar to the one transmitted
by Malik from Nafi number 443
one okay so look here's the point
because there there's actually a couple
of Renditions of this story but this is
just one of them so you have Muhammad
who puts the Torah on the Judgment seat
and he says I believe in you and the one
who revealed
you okay judgment with whom with the
Jews the Jews Like said when he came to
Medina what did he say he said everybody
go govern with your own rules among
yourself right yes that's
because the Islamic rules on anybody no
no no no he did it he did it against the
polytheist right the polytheist couldn't
abide by their own rules they had to
they had to convert or they had to they
had to go it was way late that was way
later way way later but here's the point
though notice notice how but I hear what
you're saying but notice how according
to the Quran the Jews and the Christians
are allowed to keep their law why
because that's revelation of a law the
polytheist can't keep their law
Christians don't have a law Christians
don't have a law yes they do it's it's
the the same law that Jews have is the
same you guys have just a little bit of
differ just a little bit no brother not
according to the Quran man the Quran
dude the Quran literally read verse for
example watch what the Christians are
supposed to judge by read verse 47 of
same same
chapter chapter 5: 47 read read that one
it tells you what the Christians are
supposed to judge by what their law
is oh children of Israel remember all
the all the favors I granted you and how
I honored you above all others now 547
brother chapter 5 verse
47 Sida
547 no read it read what he just said
547 this exactly what I be talking about
nobody decides to read the verse after I
don't I don't understand that you can
read the verse after we can get into
that too all right all right I'm G read
the verse before and the verse after
sure then in the footsteps of the
prophets we sent Jesus Son of Mary
confirming the torat revealed before him
and we gave him oh holy smokes what am I
doing we we in this is it this is it
this is okay I thought I thought weak
then in then in the footsteps of the
prophets we sent Jesus Son of Mary
confirming the Torah revealed before him
and we gave him the gospel containing
guidance and light and confirming what
was revealed in the torat a guide and a
lesson for the God-fearing so let the
people of the Gospel judge by what Allah
has revealed in it and those who do not
judge by what Allah has revealed are
truly the rebellious all right can we
pause there before you read the next one
we can't pause
there I I brought this for a reason okay
I promise you're going to listen to the
next verse your ignorance you PA and
read what's next let's finish the verse
you guys don't even know what I know man
y'all don't know who you're talking to
I'm telling
you we have revealed to you oh Prophet
this book with the truth as a
confirmation of previous scriptures and
a supreme authority on them so judge
between them by what Allah has revealed
and do not follow their desires over the
truth that has come to you to each of
you we have ordained a code of law and a
way of life if Allah had wailed he would
have made you one community but his will
is to test you to test you with what he
has given each of you so compete with
one another in doing good to Allah you
will all return then he will inform you
of the truth regarding your differences
I got you now now watch this because you
you spoke presumptuously you thought you
had something are you on quran.com
no you're not on quran.com we don't have
to go on the websites to get okay so
then that means y'all know the Arabic
then so what's the when it says supreme
authority when it says supreme authority
what's the Arabic word there do you guys
know
read right now I can tell you about to
read it right
now you you just you just read it
brother you just said it it's
MIM yes y do you know what MIM
means it's actually one of Allah's n 99
Names yes Al yes that's right it means
Guardian not supreme authority it means
Guardian how it works that's not how it
works that's exactly how it works you
thought you had something no see you you
don't know what you don't know what
you're talking about like I said you
don't know Arabic one word in Arabic one
word in Arabic has multiple meanings
depending on a context is used oh
interesting translation of the word
you're trying to put well I mean it's
not me because I'm looking at it see it
it's interesting the translations that
depict what what a word says because the
translation I'm looking at I'm looking
at a bunch of them they say uh what
witness over it uh guardian over it
trustworthy witness protector of it
Guardian they say the same thing they
don't say supreme
authority that's the difference between
Arabic and English if you if you want to
pick out words and give it different
translations go learn Arabic and then
you can understand well I'm looking at
the look guys I'm looking at the Corpus
I'm looking at the Arabic Corpus the
literal definition of the word mahim and
translated it's translated to Guardian
that's a literal translation not supreme
authority this English translation that
puts supreme authority is
false that's not true it is if you look
at look if you read if you read out to
have to know Arabic to say that well if
you read out toy if you read
to they have different meanings well
this what I'm saying if you read toy
guys if speak understand any Arabic guys
know what I'm saying guys I'm I'm
correct on this you can't look at Google
you can't bro I'm not I'm not a
[Laughter]
Google that's similar to being on Google
translate and speaking with somebody who
speaks another language I got hey guys
how how often are you are you
live every Tuesday man every Tuesday
okay look is it okay because I've been
here for a minute I got to get back to
my fiance is it okay if I come back on
another live go ahead go ahead bro go
ahead okay look but but let me say this
though are you married I I'll be married
in March why AR you following the law
that's real I am following the law so
look so look this this what I'm saying
this what I'm saying guys look if I if I
could just lay my last point and then I
want to thank you guys for letting me
speak actually
so my whole point is this and hopefully
we can touch on this next time we talk
that the Quran is very clear and
consistent that the previous Scriptures
it confirms it and the Jews and
Christians have possession of it if
that's the case
hold I know bro just let me just let me
L my point man please that's not the
case at all okay I hear you but let me
just at least L my point all right okay
so this this is just my stance I know
you disagree but this is just my
position okay we can talk about it next
time I see you Lord will
all right so the cross consistent that
the Jews and Christians have their
scripture which means they're
authoritative they're preserved and and
they're reliable and if this is the case
this is the Islamic dilemma because if
these previous scriptures are true and
preserved that means the Quran is false
because it contradicts these scriptures
but if these scriptures are corrupted
then the Quran is still false because
it's confirming corrupted scripture
that's my position false that's false I
hear you that's I said that's false from
the get it anything
you all right but I do want to thank you
guys man um my my my real account guys
my real account is God logic so um you
guys didn't let me up earlier but you
know I tried to get on here and talk to
you
guys yeah we appreciate you man
yeah I know some
gico that was request earlier oh oh oh
see I just want to let you guys know who
I was I wanted to show you that we can
actually have a good conversation Like
There's No Malice here man you know what
I'm saying I I had a good time I hope
y'all did too
and me a favor when you chance just read
the T for for the verse we just read I
did I read I read the top series on
these bro I read multiple that I just
read to you yeah 548 548 I read I read
iir I read tobery I read cby I read
jelane I read
multiple so I understand well well they
they have they have different opinions
so so iir he has the opinion that you
know you use the Quran as a uh you know
whatever conforms to the Quran you know
that's what's true of the previous
scripture whatever doesn't that's what's
false that's I's position you know CI
tabari and and Jalan they don't describe
it like that they they're saying that
when it says mimed that it's not that
the Quran is judging the previous
scriptures but it's a protector of them
it's a guardian of them right it guards
against the falsehood that other people
say about them you know so that's the
that's the slight difference of opinion
among the commentators I could agree
with both of those I don't think you
could I don't think you could why
wouldn't you be able to agree with both
of those because it's an inconsistent
position like one one is a is a lazy
argument to say that oh well um you know
whatever agrees with the Quran that's
the part that's good and what doesn't
agree is the bad well the Quran says in
chapter 2 verse 85 it says do you
believe in part of the scripture while
rejecting the rest those who do that
will have a disgrace in this life
scriptures with their own head that
statement is exactly because of that
they change the scriptures with their
own head mean
they know what's real and they know
what's fake and they decide to follow
they decide to mix it up basically this
yeah but this this would mean this would
mean look this would mean that Allah
himself doesn't know that their that
their scriptures are corrupted because
he's telling them to to follow it he
says what is with them is confirmed he's
telling them to follow the portion that
was not changed by
that he never says that brother he never
says that what you just said that's my
point cuz look I I want you guys to
understand I know what you're saying
brothers please you Allah answer the way
we answer well no see the thing is is
that you guys are telling Allah what he
really meant to say instead of what he
blatantly says you're like oh what Allah
means is this we telling youo I'm trying
to talk to you from which is the
explanation that the prophet taught his
companions and you trying to run away
from that and you just said that you
read the different you said you read the
and you read the of the other two
Scholars of T and then you said one
holds the opinion that whatever agrees
with the Quran we agree with and the
other two hold their opinion and the
other two hold their opinion that um
that if
um that the Quran is a guardian as it
protects what what what um what the
other scriptures brought and I'm saying
I I could agree to both of those no
because that I do believe that the
original scriptures that Allah sent down
is from him the Quran would only be
confirming whatever whatever was sent
down to now but see the other the other
ones are confirming that what they have
is from Allah that's what they're saying
bro you have you have one side look you
have one side of the of the argument
that's saying these scriptures are
completely corrupted you have the other
side that's saying they're not corrupted
but they're just misinterpreted nobody
ever said completely corrupted first of
all okay go ahead when you're adding
something to something that's perfect
you you're you're you're you're you're
it's not the same thing anymore it's not
perfect anymore but there are still
portions in it that's correct okay I got
I got that's correct that agrees with
the Quran that's what we know from Allah
because Allah is telling us yes this
this is this is correct right this is
the TRU how am I supposed to know coming
later on what's correct or not if I
don't have confirmation from God God did
you say thiss a book yes this is the
truth this is not the truth guys okay
look let me let me show you one more
thing and then I'll go let me just show
you one more thing sound like about to
go off toic well no this is no I promise
this is the same thing okay it's it's
going on what you just said that you
know uh that basically you're using the
Quran to to know what is true or what is
false in the previous scriptures okay I
have a verse that directly uh uh uh you
know um deals with this go to chapter 10
for me chapter 10 and uh it's going to
be verse
94 all right we there okay so it says um
if you are in doubt about what we have
revealed to you right then go and ask
those who've been reading the scripture
before you truly the truth come to you
from your lord be not of those who doubt
right now now I'm not looking at the
verse I I quoted that I quoted that off
the Dome just want to let y'all know
okay it don't matter it don't matter
that's besides the point be your head
and right now now like now let let's
just do this really quick let's walk
with this okay um now I'm not saying
that Muhammad is definitely in doubt it
says if it says if you're in doubt about
what we revealed to you which is the
Quran right that's that's that's that's
correct that's correct complete what
you're okay good so so if he's in doubt
about the Revelation he's getting Allah
advises him to go back to the previous
scriptures so that his doubts are
cleared up why why is
that because there's authentic things in
the original scriptures from the people
who actually read and believed in the
Original Scriptures beautiful point so
this would mean this his doubts would be
cleared up because if what he's
receiving lines up with what came before
him then he knows that his Revelation is
true right
no first of all he didn't have come on
guys come on dog you know that you know
the answer to this Allah is not saying
that he has doubts I know I'm saying if
yeah he says this specific thing that
God is telling him was was was mentioned
there in that in that in that um
original scripture that was given to the
Jews that they believe was the truth he
can still go back and see that that's
the same story but but here's the thing
though it's not about what they believe
is the truth it's about what Allah is
saying is the truth cuz Allah is sending
him from what are you talking about I
understand so what I'm saying is is that
Allah is advising Muhammad to go check
the previous scriptures to clear up if
he has any doubts so that he'll know
that what he has is the
truth so if if if you go like for
example if you if let's say let's say
your your dad is telling you a story
right let's say your dad's telling you a
story and he says if you don't believe
me go ask your
mom so why is he telling you to go to
your
mom I don't know explain to verify what
he's saying so if your if your if your
mom uh you know corroborates what your
dad was saying then you know that your
dad was telling the truth because
they're in he's lining up with what your
mom was saying so
similarly similarly the Quran is saying
if Muhammad is is doubting what he
believes about the Quran go check the
previous scriptures that way it'll clear
up any doubts that he has he'll know
that what he has is the truth if it
doesn't line up with the previous
scriptures then he'll know that what he
has is a
lie so what are you saying so what so
basically what this is showing is that
the previous scriptures are the
authority over the Quran not the other
way
around you speaking
foolish the word that came before in the
Original Scriptures is the word of God
God is Not the God is telling him the
like the same story yeah and he can tell
him yes you can find the same story in
the Original Scriptures the scriptures
that came before yeah God I just told
you that the scriptures are it's not
Islam is nothing new the same message
that Allah sent before he's sending his
his Messenger to to to reinforce to send
again so then why is it Allah always
refers his Prophet Allah tells his
prophet in the Quran look at the
previous prophets who came before you
there his examples Jesus is the example
of the Prophet M where would he get
these where where would he get these
previous prophets from where would he
get these stories what you say what did
you say what did you say if Muhammad
wanted if Muhammad wanted to check the
previous prophets to make sure that he's
getting good Revelation and he's in line
with them where would he
go what talking about the original the
reation saying he check the stories he
would have to check the previous
scriptures right no he would not first
of all first of all that's what it says
if you're in doubt go check the previous
scriptures no you think you think you
think the prophet doesn't know who the
prophets before him are is that what
you're trying to say that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying to confirm his own
Revelations if he's doubting any of them
he has to go to the previous scriptures
to make sure that his doubt that he's
that he's good that he's in line with it
so it'll clear up any doubts that he has
he's not doubting any of what are you
saying it says if he's doubting if he's
doubting look just like the example I
gave you earlier if you don't believe
what I'm saying go ask your mom she'll
tell you so that means me that when you
go check what what your what what I'm
saying with my mom with your mom you'll
know that I'm telling the truth the same
way here if you go check the previous
scriptures then you'll know that what
Allah what I'm giving you Muhammad is
the
truth go ask go ask the people who
reading the book before you you'll
see now if he if he if he doesn't if if
what he's getting does not line up with
what the previous scriptures say then he
has good reason to doubt what he's
receiving that's the
points okay so that means that the
previous scriptures are an authority or
a judge or a verifier of the Quran it's
not the other way
around no that is not the truth no no no
no no okay look guys I do have to go but
look think about this okay because I
think this is a good point and you guys
are some thinkers I could tell check it
out Ponder on it think about it and and
we'll talk next time okay uh King Sil is
a is a next time next time next time you
you you decide go on verses make sure
you read two verses before and then two
ver brother I I I know the I know the
whole Quran man trust me as you guys as
you I know I know the Quran bro I I I
know
it I know the context of these vers I I
I don't read look I try to treat the
Quran like I treat my Bible you know I
read it in its context I don't
misrepresent it you know I try to be as
Fair as I
[Music]
can all right you guys take care okay oh
my God logic
a
[Music]